Eddie Murphy's returning to us to know
the host after 35 years Wow yeah you
know December they're gonna let me tell
you right now it's gonna be it's a
different world you can't be dropping
that bomb he's coming back to a
different climate you know see ya I'm
interested with that because if you
watch Eddie stand up right he dropped a
lot of he said [ __ ] that's a lot yeah
a time oh yeah we're very well yeah
right you know there so that's yeah
however there's rumors that he swings
that way so if it's not just rumors he's
been arrested never tell it's dark it's
late well you might judge the man right
but the thing is is this you just swing
that way so I'm curious if all the the
haters come out and they start bringing
up old tweets like they did a [ __ ]
well he wasn't Trevor but they're gonna
say oh look at his materials drop mine I
think pop can we see this guy know what
if he comes out - excuse me dude yeah
yeah [ __ ]
I'm more worried that he's not funny
then he'll be hateful like I'm actually
he's too smart for that like you turd
you know too smart for it right I'm
gonna come back and ruin him he's one of
the greatest performers to have ever
never ever comics I'm excited to see
whatever he does you know nothing to be
sad if he came back in just eight days
well he knows he knows he was talking
about how Stanek doesn't give a [ __ ]
about you you've got to get back on the
road do you hit on the community cards
he and coffee he talked about he's like
oh no I'm gonna start doing clubs I'm a
staff there he goes you can't take a
long time off and jump back in no you
gotta you gotta watch Chappelle's
special it's brilliant
amazing amazing I didn't watch you're in
the paint best living comic right now I
think oh hey I mean hands down and top
three of all time top three yes the one
read him and in the jumper yeah yeah
when did it what did it two days two
days ago great you know if you keep
watching it it stops and there's a Q&A a
secret key idea interesting it's cool
he's getting he's getting [ __ ] for going
they've gone being misogynistic and no I
mean just on this toilet rolls like it's
like II repeat like it's like not even
how about why schools don't watch you're
special like you [ __ ] if I said that you
know everybody's can watch a special no
vice by the way is
looking to get acquired like they're
waiting to get bought yeah nobody has
bought them so I think all the me to
movements but yeah the title of their
thing was like hey pass on Chappelle
specialist like yeah that's what every
media conglomerates doing to you right
now even as everyone's felt like we're
gonna [ __ ] yourself an advising Jeff
let's skip Dave Chappelle's new net for
special Wow stick yeah pounds it's so
good he owes he addresses everything
goes so hard in the pain yeah cuz I feel
like if you don't like that you don't
like comedy really if you don't like the
new Chapelle special then just stand-up
comedy maybe not your it's so good yeah
I think it's this best one mine will be
better I will say that and then Williams
King in June and I that could be the
Kido talking because it's filled me with
a an unhealthy confidence but I think we
to be out of the week yeah I think I'll
be better than him in like three days
that makes it right who knows yeah he
goes hard in the paint though man it's
really right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]